- [Voiceover] Approach,
open your arms up wide
like a proud eagle and then tilt your head
in whichever direction
you feel comfortable,
slightly raise your arm in the direction
of your tilted head.
This will indicate your
intention to your partner
and prevent any head to head collisions.
Finally glide in slowly and confidently.
The squeeze, maintaining your body
in a semi-ridgid manner will indicate
to your friend that you are
in control of the embrace.
Make sure your arms are
not like wet noodles
but rather like the warm
branches of a firm oak.
Turn your head out at this point
and stare into the horizon.
Turning your head inwards
can indicate sexual interest
only do this if this is
your given intention.
The pat, the pat is the staple
of any good man hug.
This will deliniate this
cloth from just a regular hug.
Now is your time to shine.
Put your own creative spin on the pat.
Do you like to use a fist or
an open handed karate chop?
Whatever the gesture make sure it is firm,
confident and filled with spirit.
The break, the duration of the hug
should be felt out situationally
and the break should be done confidently
as you made your approach.
If you limp away at this moment
then all of your hard work will be lost.
The handshake-to-hug.
Engage your friend with your dominant hand
and deliver a firm handshake.
Pull your friend close and
swing your elbow behind you.
Open your opposite hand
and then proceed through
the previous steps.
Make sure to keep the hand throughout
the hug duration.
(upbeat music)